welcome to this video playing wgm Jelani
from from russia Irina Bokova okay
that once it's okay at least not the
default line with 93 not that it is so
so brilliant but this is a line that
requires some more concrete knowledge
and I really don't know the theory too
well in this opening really it surprises
me
why do you want to exchange I thought
that this would help me okay where'd you
go probably hear the slightest b69 is
going to a to d5
yeah this kind of structure is always
some bit tricky because that because
black gets the d5 square but he's
suffering a bit from lack of space what
about C Phi F is this may mean G for is
the idea and I need to move the NIE
probably back somewhere but other place
c5 I'm attacking G for the only question
is is this an untimely untimely idea
with with like not being fully developed
but I still like it I still like it
using the unprotected state of the Queen
yeah it's probably probably the right
decision anyway G for my take on G phone
you know this is the the conventional
way to play and probably the right one
okay grab him and and trade trade pieces
hmm okay I just thought taking an
tonight CT v the the easiest way to play
however however
97 are taking your father never probably
not let's just put it on d5 if this is
the big asset that black has the great
square on one d5 and you should really
use it
hmm yeah should I give the check and and
I have some I have some coordination
issues this Bishop here and tonight my
bishop 1f8 is not able to move what
about bishop before yeah I have a net
get rid of one look I'm not I'm not sure
I don't but check this was my idea using
this temple on the rook or the King but
how to play now if I go King be seven
and 93 I can take with the bishop
there's III however
yeah it's a bit a bit turkey the bit
tricky this position my bet development
is sir
this is a serious issue okay still let's
do that
a3 I'm going here 95 Kings is 6
I don't think check hmm I thought this
would be okay yeah but this Roxy phone
simply works you form maybe here maybe
go here and go to don't go to be 8 I
know it looks it looks creepy but I
don't see I don't see a direct problem
check - yeah go to a head check
or to see soon maybe here it's no
intending be 6v6 King be seven maybe at
the end the this night can prove for
liability be six is basically trapping
the night and then King be seven Bishop
d8 at the end the night has North Corral
maybe this is in fact the tricky tricky
IDM and if Knight c5 now I can check in
five hmm maybe quite a capable like yeah
it's all about this great night on g5
hmm this looks like a strange move
yeah okay I'll trap the night now now
there's even look the eight immediately
threatened Bishop d8 that was rook c8 I
need to prepare that so now Bishop d8
takes rook takes and the disrupt some
some as simple as that
and Bishop d8 if white plays any move I
take g5 play up the aid and again it's
trapped yeah I think I'm just ruining
the night as weird as it is it's trapped
they had I think she's she's not finding
any solution to this problem and
therefore spending so much time this not
really got lost inside of black scam
shack yeah relatively I mean okay it's
it's it's relatively easy now I block
the ship horn book p8 coming it's an
easy technical task yeah this was very
very stranger quite quite out of the
blue I was I was winning Lucas for get
to get it to be eight
I can always grab material look PA to be
five white resigned this was strange
very strange game it really I don't know
I I mean black shouldn't be in trouble
that's that's pretty optimistic about
that but it's it's very tricky because
my okay Jade is not playing and what I
did here maybe there maybe white has
some way to play it more precisely
maybe rook c4 here for example check I
mean this this is not losing or anything
no no doubt but probably like this seven
is really not the the best the best idea
Jack
the dreams tempting but yeah after
before it's really losing such harmless
looking move the computer immediately
goes on black Winningham because after
Bishop see several now night see file is
the only move not losing the night and
this drops the e5
so this is the relatively best
continuation but it's the super
important e5 pawn and after that yeah
it's it's really lost this piece check
quite quite remarkable
yeah the cow chromosome and immensely
solid opening ready check yeah so this
should should be an equal ish maybe
something like this is what what
improves taking control here but still
if I just play play here yeah the the
space the space I need to go all the way
back out to e7 which is slightly
annoying and if I go here something like
g4 yeah what keeps keep some some edge
here this for example can lead to a
person yeah white is white can certainly
improve in there in the opening
maybe this c5 which which I really liked
it's a not such a such a great idea
yellow it's not a Correspondence game
can analyze it more deeply thanks for
watching